(audience claps)
- I love your hair!
Your hair is so beautiful!
(audience cheers)
You smell beautiful, you look beautiful--
- Thank you!
I just came from work!
Hi, everybody!
- Oh my gosh!
- I got dressed in my dressing room.
(Tichina laughs)
- Oh, you look really,
that's where you do it, though--
- Thank you!
- So good job!
You know each other though, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yes.
He and I, we went to Israel together!
- That's so random!
- We went with this group
called The Creative Coalition.
It's kind of a bunch of
artists and industry people
went to Israel, and can I just tell,
the highlight for me was
when we climbed Masada.
- Mount Masada. It was beautiful.
- Is this, you know, ancient fortress,
and one of the big things is that you do
this really steep, long, hot hike.
Everybody was ready, and
everybody had their boots
and gear, and you know, Tichina comes by
and she's looking beautiful,
I'm not exaggerating, wearing heels.
(Tichina laughs)
Okay, and her bag!
And a pocketbook.
- Just in case we got stranded!
(audience laughs)
Listen, we can live two weeks
off the stuff in my pocketbook.
(Steven laughs)
- That's her bug out bag. (laughs)
- She looked amazing, beautiful,
this beautiful woman in heels walking up
this deadly hike to an ancient fortress.
That was my favorite memory.
- I did it, I did it.
You know what, it was just
such a wonderful experience.
And then even, you know,
getting in the Dead Sea.
- Yeah, that's right.
- [Kelly] I've always wanted to do that!
- You gotta go.
I think it should be the
eighth Wonder of the World.
- That's so cool!
- It's really amazing.
But we had a good time.
We're buddies.
- You just can't shave before you go
into the Dead Sea.
- Yeah.
- I'm just gonna, oh that would burn.
- (Steven) That'd burn.
- (laughs) Yeah.
I'm just gonna let you know though,
momma doesn't wear heels unless
I'm being paid, so. (laughs)
- You know what?
- I don't wear heels.
(audience claps)
Nope, nope!
But you are on a classic
sitcom that I loved as well
♪ Martin ♪
with Sheneneh,
I love the whole show. I
thought it was so good.
So what's, other than
people being a fool like me
and just singing the song
Martin, what do people do?
They still come up to you
and ask you about that?
- Oh man, they go, "Pam!"
(everyone laughs)
I don't even answer to my own,
I don't answer to my own name anymore.
- You're like, "My name is not Pam."
- But you know what's gratifying for me
is to know that I did a show,
you know, 28 years ago,
and people still enjoy it.
God has blessed me to
do what I love doing,
and being on Martin all those years,
we just really had a good time,
and for us to see people laugh at it,
laughter makes the world go round.
It makes the spirit and the soul better.
(audience claps)
We need to laugh.
So I'm happy that people still enjoy it.
- Yes!
We've literally had all of your costars
from The Neighborhood on here.
- Yes, and I'm happy I finally made it
to your damn show!
(Steven laughs)
- Well, I'm happy you
finally found time!
- What!
(Kelly laughs)
Yes!
- No, did they speak well of us?
Were they like, "It's so great!"
- Beth came back to the
set, and she was like,
"Oh my god! I love Kelly!
"Kelly, oh, I had so
much fun on the show!"
Yeah, she loved it. They all did.
Everybody leaves here--
- You know, she introduced me
to Marie Kondo, and then
Marie Kondo came on the show,
and we had her back.
Do you know Marie Kondo?
- Beth is in love with her.
Beth loves her.
- I thought Beth was nuts,
'cause just that part, 'cause I was like,
"What is this Marie Kondo thing?"
I had never heard of it.
I am obsessed!
- I'm a little OCD too, so it works.
Like, organizing,
ever since I had my daughter,
which was 15 years ago,
I'm still trying to organize my life.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
Seriously.
Children, they change your life forever
in a good way but in also other ways.
- Yeah, sometimes just tornadoes--
- Yeah! (laughs)
- So Cedric told me
about his neighborhood,
so what was yours like growing up?
- Oh god, you know I was born and raised
in Jamaica, Queens.
- Queens!
- Yeah!
- Both of you are Queens, that's right!
(audience cheers)
- Queens has a lot of great people,
lotta talented people, but
I lived in a small, like,
I couldn't go past a one block radius.
Everything was according to your block,
"What block did you live on?"
And so when rap came out, we were able
to hear rap songs from the
Bronx and Brooklyn so you knew,
that's what rap was about.
But being from Queens
during the '90s and the '80s
it was a good neighborhood.
I was a little kid, I would
walk in people's doors,
everybody left the door unlocked--
- Oh no!
- And we'd watch
each other's kids,
but it's a little (laughs)--
- Nope!
- But it's a very blue-collar burrow
with amazing diversity.
It was never the coolest burrow,
but now it's got a best food,
it's got an amazing
neighborhood, so it's--
- I always tell people,
whenever you land at JFK,
I lived like, seven blocks from JFK.
I remember the big planes
would come in at night,
the Concord would come in
really, really, really--
- Windows rattle.
- My whole house would shake.
- We had a train behind us, yeah.
- Same thing!
I think we all have similar neighborhoods,
in a way, where it is about community.
- Yeah!
- A neighborhood is
always about community,
and even if you don't know someone,
like, I try to make a difference
by not being shut off from people,
and if I get new neighbors I'm like,
"Hey, how you doing?"
- Trying not to be fearful of
something you may not know.
- I'm not fearful, I just wanna make sure
they ain't trying to steal my stuff.
(everyone laughs)
(audience claps)
- I'm just introducing myself
so I know who to find.
Who to find later.
I wanna see your face!
- I need to see who's
gonna be in this house!
- It's harder to steal from someone
when you're looking 'em in the eyes!
- Early identification program.
(Tichina and Kelly laugh)
- That was the first round, yes.
So your daughter is almost 16.
What's she like?
We have a three, five,
13, and 18 year old.
- I mean, you lost me
after the second one.
- No, but a teenager!
That can be trying.
- Oh my god, just keep us in your prayers.
My daughter,
(Kelly laughs)
it's hard to watch herself.
She's like, now that she's
older it's like watching myself.
It's scary.
But what I'm so grateful to
God for is that I am a woman
and I can teach her how to be a woman.
(audience claps)
Had I had a male child,
it would've been a little different.
I was a single mom, which
I did not expect to be,
I didn't have her until
I was 35 years old,
so had already had career first,
and then kinda, you know,
got into motherhood.
I think it's been the most gratifying,
amazing, and just rocky road
that I've ever taken in my life,
but she's that one person that I would die
in the blink of an eye for.
So it's motherhood first
and then everything else.
(audience claps)
- There's so much love,
and then sometimes there's
so much dislike. (laughs)
- No!
- [Kelly] There's so much love, but yeah,
sometimes I'm like--
- You've got four--
- "I love you, but I
don't like you right now,
"so for your safety you should
leave my presence." (laughs)
- That's because they didn't know us
before we were moms!
I keep telling her, I was like, "Yo!
(Kelly laughs)
"I used to be somebody
before I was your mother!
"And you might be meeting
this person real soon!"
(audience laughs and claps)
- And you--
- "Do you wanna meet that person?"
- All right, take it easy.
Take it easy there.
- And it's like, "And
apologize for what you did
"to my body. That's all I want."
- It's too good.
I give it up to mothers.
God bless you. I think it's wonderful--
- I love being a mother.
I never thought I'd be one.
My mom is still like, "Oh my god,
"you have children and a husband."
- Hey, ain't no problem. (laughs)
- But Tichina, you've got a way,
this is my favorite thing I've ever heard
with parenting,
you've got a way with your daughter
to kind of punish her, and
it deals with a cell phone.
- Oh, most definitely.
We live in a day and age
where we all have cell phones.
We are attached to our devices,
and you know, I tried
taking the cell phone
away from her, which it
wasn't really advantageous
for me because she takes Uber sometimes,
and we need the cell phone.
So, "Okay, Imma get you a flip phone."
- Ooh, wait a minute.
- I got a flip phone,
and now everything goes
through my phone, so I know how
to shut her down when I need to.
There's a way of punishing someone
without not having contact with them.
We can still have contact,
but I had to give her a flip phone
because it's all the control I have.
- When she's with her friends
and she pulls out her
Ferris Bueller phone--
- Yeah! Oh yeah!
Take it back to the old days.
That's when mommy had a flip phone,
you can have a flip phone, too!
- Give her a beeper!
(audience claps)
(everyone laughs)
I love you!
Oh my god!